you see the type of organization we have
here
we can always use a man like you nathan
educated war veteran clean record
and so what's the overall objective
this is revolutionary activity we're
talking about here
i need an informant get in there and
make a difference
we are a thinking man soldiers first day
and then here
we know where you live i don't have
skills for this i can't even defend
myself you do have the skills
try relating to these guys as human
beings
let me see what we want to see but just
because you're not looking at something
get your hands off me doesn't mean it's
not there
you okay there nate look a little off
big things are coming an event
that wakes people up massive terrorist
plot
this morning in america and there's a
new day
coming are you a cop
these guys are fanatics they will not be
taken away
for evil to triumph it only takes good
men
to do nothing
let me ask you something nathan what's
your opinion on infiltration
do you suspect someone ah it's just you
know it's like they say at these
rallies looks left look to the right
one of these people is a snitch
what's the
it's left 40 minutes 38 minutes what
should i do now
whatever you want the deputy director of
the nsa
offered me a new position can you tell
me anything about it